what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers compete in one musical variety
show welcome to a very special episode
of the champ vision I am your host
Sergio Ramos let's get started with our
first act since real one last year I've
been forced to host the UEFA vision ok
so why you and now on your teammates
don't want me here pay me I'll live
[Music]
we are messy we are pursued these are
fake titties are when we are not blowing
three gold leads we are we are messy or
we are messy it's time to show this time
but we are so much better than Christina
Rosa ladies and gentlemen my wife
Shakira
[Applause]
game what we need Spurs we'll look at
jokes put those two games at a time and
you best believe the second week show
now it's transfer time we go Josh
so how was IX I skipped the second half
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well pay pay who would have guessed
so sort of hoping that since I'm leaving
I wouldn't have to join Dortmund on
stage let's just say the German
performances can get pretty out there
who like our yellow ball now face our
wall of noise this is guys
santa lucia shoka no fear
this indeed can happen
[Music]
[Music]
next up Atletico the poor man's Madrid
singing for us will be my best friend
Drake fill up in my dance but think I'm
gonna block it punch and talk honey
Amaya watching Sarkis they want to go to
club but I can't god forbid his Lord
knows I'm a big supporter huh Atletico
Madrid
wait that letter goes out who's in
Liverpool sir yeah growing up in Canada
I've always been a huge fan of Liverpool
[Music]
and that was PSG demonstrating why team
art is important and now for something
completely different to many English
teams
that's the same craft they played last
year why do you think they have a chance
this time
[Music]
he's good yeah
[Music]
so my just
so
funny how
it's gone
aha wait so he can sing in English but
he only speaks Spanish I don't get it
I'll be jostled man together with one
man United no their Josie is gone I came
in like a car
ok ladies and gentlemen once again
Shakira
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
subscribe to be a football if you sink
Liverpool within the Champions League
and not subscribe if you think
pardonable win the Champions League wait
no no no don't do that subscribing